the physics training is a very good
training
where
uh it's a good framework for reasoning
where you're trained to
think about first principles and reason
from there
and that means boiling things down to
the most fundamental truths and then
connecting those truths in a way
to to try to understand
how reality is
because you know physics has this
problem where they're trying to figure
out things that are totally
counterintuitive
and so they had to have a framework for
for getting there like quantum mechanics
is incredibly counter-intuitive
but it's true
um and so you had so physics developed a
framework for for figuring out
uh things that aren't obvious and that's
why i think it's it's not it's it's a
lot of advice but it's
it's the right framework wanna be happy
build a life not just a business hey
it's evan carmichael and this channel
was created to help you overcome the
number one challenge that is holding you
back a lack of belief in yourself you
watch these videos because you know
there's something more inside you too
you've got michael jordan level genius
at something so today let's live your
best belief life and learn the seven
rich people habits that you need to try
enjoy
habit number two have self-confidence
with bill gates i think having some
self-confidence uh
is different than finding your passion
from a young age ideally you'll have
adults in your life
preferably your parents as part of that
some of your teachers
people around you who
who like you and they're behind you and
they'll back you
no matter what goes on and that gives
you enough confidence to go off on a
quest and during that quest you try
different things out if you're lucky
when you're very young you find
something you're passionate about
i did when i was 13 years old i found
computers and software it took me
another five years to figure out that
was my
life's uh primary work
but that's a lucky thing other people
you know get out into their 20s or even
later before they find
what they're passionate about but
proceeding with a certain set of
self-confidence that there are people
who care for you you care for them that
you succeed in their eyes by your
uh
how you treat them i think that's that's
pretty basic and it gives you the
platform on which to try out new things
to fail you know first you're not going
to succeed in in various things so
self-confidence is primary and then
finding your passion is a
an adventure a quest that that may take
time and it may switch over the time
time of your life but those deep
relationships will let you uh pursue it
with bigger habit number three have
discipline with warren buffett you don't
need 150 iq to do what i do thank god
you know you don't need 140 you know 135
you may need 115 or something like that
and
and but you do need discipline
you have to wait until you see the fat
pitch to swing at
because investing is a no-call strike
game you know if i were a baseball
player and i only like pitches
two inches above my navel
you know some guy could learn that and
he could pitch me you know three or four
inches below that and i get called out
on strikes because i never find a pitch
i like you can get called out on strikes
in baseball
you have to you have to swing at pitches
that you you don't even necessarily like
particularly after the count gets to two
strikes
in business
you don't have to swing at anything you
can sit there and
the paper says general motors at 68 or
it says general electric at 115 or says
general dynamics at 63.
and if you don't like those prices you
don't have to swing you can wait there
day after day after day after day and
there are no called strikes
now when you swing when you decide to
buy something
then you know if you swing and miss it's
a strike but it's a marvelous game to be
in because there are no called strikes
and you can simply wait for that one
time
in a month or six months or a year or
two or three years when you really know
what you're doing where you like the
price where you like the people running
the business
and then you swing and you only need a
few swings in your lifetime also to make
sure you're actually taking action after
watching this video i've designed a
special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the lessons learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there habit number four be passion
driven with oprah winfrey for me
i've already made more money than i
expected i've already got more shoes
than i know
and i'm like okay what to do with the
shoes
you know so and it never was about
material possessions i don't think if i
could have um
if i'd sat down
and said how do i dream myself up to be
able to get all this i wouldn't have
known how to do it so i was driven by a
passion that was bigger than the show in
the beginning and i believe that in
order to continue every person has a
responsibility to use their life
you
everybody who came here today your life
may not be as big as mine meaning not as
many people know you and the only
difference between being famous and not
is that more people know your name the
real reality is what billy was singing
and what
um maddie talks about in his poetry is
that we are really all alike
except for our hair we are really
we are really all alike and that has
been one of the greatest lessons i've
learned in doing this television show is
that what everybody is looking for
is validation yeah in every experience
people are looking to know that they
matter that you matter that i matter and
every encounter and all your fights at
home all your arguments with your boss
or with your children with your husband
when you really peel back the layers and
get down to what is what is this what
are we arguing about you're arguing you
want to say i matter and i think that um
um
what we've been able to do on this show
is to help people see that for
themselves and if i can be able to give
that back to people in a way that makes
them matter to themselves then this is
worth
billions of dollars
it's priceless it's priceless to be able
to do that habit number five be clear
with mark zuckerberg the hardest thing
for me early on
was
because i i just started off as i was
i was an engineer or you know i wasn't
even really an engineer as a student
right it's i i thought i was going to be
an engineer when i graduated
and
you know when you're when you're
building something yourself
you kind of you have all the meetings in
your head right it's like you don't need
to articulate the principles so clearly
it's like you kind of can make all the
trade-offs on on everything from
architecture to product to marketing to
you know just all these things and
you're kind of just you have the context
to trade this off
and
i think it's really
easy when you start
building something to um
to underestimate
how much context you need to put out
there and how clear you need to be about
what you're trying to do so you know
most of my mistakes early on in building
the company
were about not being clear enough
internally about what we were trying to
do and there's this very famous
episode where
where like
in 2006 a couple years into building the
company
yahoo tried to buy us and
so they offered a ton of money
and
a lot of the people who who i'd hired at
the point they were kind of experienced
technology executives and this was like
all of their startup dream come true
right they joined and then you know
within you know a year or a few months
like the the company had the opportunity
to exit for this large amount of money
and
[Music]
you know i really
failed through that period to
communicate what we were trying to do
and what we
what we stood for
and
in the absence of that
that context then of course it was a
rational thing for people to think that
this was like a good outcome for us to
have habit number six expose yourself to
new things with mark cuban same thing i
told myself the same thing i tell
everybody
one you're 21 22 23 years old right you
don't have to figure it out right now
don't try
right you spend all this money
sorry
um
pain to learn
now it's your chance to get paid to
learn
you don't need the perfect job
you just need to go somewhere where
you'll learn and start to be exposed to
different ideas and now it's not like
you know when when greg 40 years ago was
graduating
and me five years ago
you know it was like get a career
and you know the pressure was get a
career go work for ibm or general motors
and get a pension those days are gone
people can't even pay their pensions
anymore and so you're a free agent
and you're always going to be a free
agent on the market you guys are the
kevin durants and lebron james you know
where you're always out there and can go
find a better situation for yourself
do what's best for you what have you got
to lose like when i started my company
you know after i got fired by michael
yumeki um
um
you know what was good how bad could it
be i would lose my motel 6 towel you
know
it was just like what have you got to
lose and yeah i understand there's
pressures from student loans and there's
a lot of conversations we can have there
right but you know you can get a job
that doesn't have to be perfect you can
learn at that job and you guys have the
pedigree you have the brains you have
the initiative to go out and try the
next job you know
you know the good news is the economy is
good enough that it may not be perfect
but you can go job to job don't look for
the perfect answer just look to get the
experience look to learn because all
these different exposures all the
different things you learn learning how
to learn
that's what's going to give you get you
excited and juicy for for something that
you love because once you find something
you love to do
that's when the magic happens
because when you're when you're able to
find something you love to do then you
can start work focusing on how can i be
great at this
and like greg found out he was a great
networker i like to you know play with
technology and try to do things first
you know whatever it is that you find
about yourself then you can try to be
great at it and it's rare when people
quit things they're great at
you know and so trying those things so
that that's how i advise people don't
don't stress just go out and try
different things and habit number seven
the last one before some very special
bonus clips is reset your motivation
with stephen bartlett every year around
february march i say the same thing to
myself and i set myself the same goal
let's just stop there right and take a
look at what i just said because there's
a real clue in that first sentence why
does this goal pop up in march
the answer quite an obvious one because
summer is on the horizon
and you could ask yourself again you got
to criticize yourself there and say well
why does summer matter well because you
know summertime is a time where we wear
less clothes we're a little bit more
vulnerable our bodies are on show more
and then you can ask yourself okay so
why is that relevant well it speaks to
the nature of my motivation my
motivation wasn't to work out it wasn't
to be healthy because i want long-term
health benefits or to or to feel great
about myself as embarrassing as this is
to admit my motivation was so clearly
clearly
to look good for summer
let's just break that down a second
look good for summer looking good as a
goal is measured by just one thing the
public's opinion of me
ladies opinion of me
that's what we call an extrinsic
external goal success of that goal will
be achieved when the public think i look
good the next part of that sentence
right was for
summer the next part of my goal was for
summer which is a measurable time frame
so once summer is over
the job is done so the motivation behind
that goal was both extrinsic and held
within a time frame so when i dropped
that social media pick of me topless in
mykonos or wherever i went this summer
mykonos and costa rica looking good
during summer and when i got the
compliments the likes the followers the
praise and when summer passed
unsurprisingly
so did my motivation
job done
my goal my reason my why was attached to
summer and also public opinion and both
had been fulfilled so as i pulled into
october and i tried to find the
motivation to go to the gym it was gone
going to the gym suddenly felt so
pointless to me and i had no idea why it
just did even when i managed to get to
the gym my workout was quite honestly
pathetic it was short it was like 25 30
minutes of me predominantly texting and
i didn't know why i just thought i
wasn't feeling great like you know like
a boat that had suddenly been unanchored
i was now just drifting unconsciously
without intention or real motivation or
without conscious realization into the
winter months into bad habits into fat
steve and the minute i realized this
this year i was able to completely reset
and sort of re-anchor my motivation into
things that were intrinsically
internally motivating and without time
frames i set myself the goal of going to
the gym just because it makes me feel
great and because of the energy it gives
me and the positive impact it has on my
sleep and because you know i love
showing myself how self-disciplined i am
i get a real weird feeling of joy
by going to the gym on a day when i feel
like [ __ ] because for me that's kind of
overcoming my mind right it's like
beating um the the negative or the the
weaker parts of my mind that are trying
to dissuade me from doing something
that's in line with my long-term values
the law of compensation is exact
the law of compensation clearly states
the amount of money you earn
will be an exact ratio to these three
points number one the need for what you
do the need for what you do number two
your ability to do it and number three
that difficulty there will be in
replacing you now think of that
number one the need for what you do
number two your ability to do it and
number three the difficulty there isn't
replacing you
now odds are pretty good the need for
what you do is already there you don't
have to do anything about that
number three will be taken care of if
you take care of number two
you may want to think about this for a
little while i thought about it for a
long while and i realized
it's pretty true
so you see you only have to focus on one
of those three points and that is number
two
your ability to do it whatever you're
doing you want to get better at it just
keep working at getting better at what
you're doing and there isn't any
competition you're the only compa
competition you're ever going to have
master whatever you do master it like
any entrepreneur
when you start a business
you start to worry and people around you
worry much more than you do
when i start alibaba my parents worry my
wife worry my friends were in my
teacher's world my students where
everybody worry and they worry about a
lot of things the only thing that i
worry
is that
i should not disappoint the people who
believe in me
and when we study the alibaba
we have a lot of things people worry you
know when we study alibaba say hey
you don't have a payment you don't have
a trust people do not believe in online
they believe in face to face
meeting and government does not support
internet nobody supported e-commerce how
could you do it
i think
as an entrepreneur
if everything is ready
that does not need you
because nothing is ready that needs
entrepreneurship for counterfeit things
of course
there are lot
at the beginning
but you have to fix it
so in the past 15 years we spend a lot
of time because you have to making sure
the customer feels safe
happy
the brand of you're happy
your reputation is the repetition your
reputation is the best otherwise the
people say i sell on the site and my
things were copied and stolen
so we
using a lot of ways to do that today
more than a hundred thousand
brands
partner with us so the story that i tell
is of a man and i heard this story from
a guy named david bednar but
who's an educator and a religious leader
but basically
the story is
a man in his truck and this was i think
back in the 70s
um he wanted to test out his new pickup
truck you know and i think he lived out
like you know somewhere in the u.s like
in the rocky mountains where it snows a
lot and so he drove up the mountains up
in the snow and he was just gonna test
his truck and he was a little
overconfident in this thing anyways he
ended up getting stuck in some really
deep snow and he was trying to peel out
his tires and couldn't get himself out
and so
he didn't know what to do like and this
was back again before cell phone so it's
not like he could just call home like he
was out there in the like up in the
mountains by himself
so ultimately what he ended up doing
you know was getting out and he started
chopping down a tree and cutting up
firewood and he's you know he stuck
while he was just waiting and just
hoping that someone would drive by so he
could flag him down but ultimately no
one came and he ended up you know
chopping up you know chopping up a tree
and putting it in the back of his truck
totally filling up the bed of his truck
and then no one came and it was getting
darker and darker colder and colder
so he got in his car you know turned on
the car said a prayer and then um
tried to back out of the of the snow and
actually because of the weight of the
wood he was able to get traction which
ultimately allowed him to get out he
wouldn't have been able to get traction
in his tires but because of the weight
of all that wood he was able to get out
and so the idea is that you need a load
of wood or he needed a heavy load to
actually get traction and move forward
or get out of the bad situation or to
move forward and the principle is the
same for what i felt in my own life like
for years i'd wanted to be a writer but
i didn't really have any you know i
didn't have a load on you know on me i
didn't you know and this is what we're
talking about as far as responsibility
like a load of responsibility like i i
had a lot of time and when you have a
lot of time when you have a lot of
freedom and flexibility it's really easy
to waste that time
and so once we got these three foster
kids it was seriously from my
perspective equivalent to
the load of wood in the back of that
truck like it was it was in my life like
these three kids were
a heavy load for me and my wife like it
was intense but interestingly and kind
of as you said counter-intuitively
it really gave me traction it gave me
motivation it gave me inspiration it
created urgency and so i
you know very shortly after we got these
kids i started waking up early and
started writing and started moving on
with my goals and getting more committed
um and
it's amazing how you can get committed
in life and it's amazing once you truly
commit to a future and commit to what
you want and when you just
start waking up early and start rocking
towards your goals uh things can change
you know and seriously within like three
or four months of writing online like
my blogs were blowing up being read by
millions of people and i just had a
level of urgency and excitement towards
my future and i i give a lot of credit
to that load of responsibility that i
had which was my kids which you know you
wouldn't have expected you know you'd
expect that actually you'd be more
overwhelmed or you would
procrastinate your dreams even more but
for me it was just like just the
traction i needed to like really get
focused and committed i was in
johannesburg a little while ago and i
went through the the airport
and i went into the men's room or
washroom or bathroom however you want to
call it and so i walked in to the men's
room and the first thing i hear is
welcome to my office
and this was the janitor at the
johannesburg
men's room that's funny who who
janitorized or i'll make up a word
cleaned the men's the toilets
like
mozart composed music now that man has
no money that man probably has very
little education
that man is judged by the world as
having an unimportant job right and that
man is a hero could be a hero to
millions of people why because he
actually saw himself as an ambassador to
south africa and he his passion was was
palpable and his visceral commitment to
doing work at the highest level
was like you don't see even from the
ceos and all i'm saying is
even the person in the
with the broken heart the person who's
down on their knees whether they see it
or not they have a choice to rise above
their circumstances and leadership and
humanity is a testament to the people
who have done it i mean you re read the
group you look at mandela you know 27
years in imprisonment when his son died
he wasn't allowed to attend the funeral
of his own son he said that was the one
of the great pains of his own of his
life
and what did he do
the victim looks at something like that
torture and says i am broken
and they give up and they spend they
close their heart they close their mind
they close their creativity and they
blame the rest of their life on what
happened to them but mandela what he
chose to do was to use it as an
opportunity because actually
the things that break your heart if you
choose can open your heart and
fear the world says fear is bad fear is
only an opportunity for bravery training
and what he did was he used those 27
years of torture to open his himself
mentally physically emotionally and
spiritually to the point where when he
was released and became the president of
south africa he invited his jailers to
sit in the front row at his inauguration
and he was asked why and he said because
if i don't i'm still gonna i'd still be
in prison and that's a long way of
saying but you know we do make excuses
because we are very good at
self-deception because if we actually
had to face the responsibility of
playing with our bigness in the world
we'd have to let go of our addiction to
our excuses and and leave what's safe am
i making sense no totally no totally
you'd have to leave what's safe i mean
we are addicted to crisis sometimes it
makes no sense we are addicted to pain
and we'd have to actually leave the pain
to go out to the possibility of pleasure
and joy and greatness
and believe it or not that frightens us
right so we make these excuses and then
we blame people oh joe or robin i don't
like the way he looks i he he speaks
differently but subconsciously as you're
suggesting those are just our protective
mechanisms
to avoid
owning the responsibility of our
brilliance i also knew that like of
course i'd have to work really really
hard if i was ever going to make it of
course i'd have to get back up every
time i got knocked down on the journey
but i knew if i was gonna make it like
the most important thing came down to me
believing that i could
and for me
you know
and here's the thing a lot of times we
hold ourselves back because we say
things to ourselves like oh i'm not
qualified or oh i feel this like dream
on my heart to whatever it is launch a
podcast whatever it is but it's like oh
but i'm you know don't know how and i
don't know i have no connections and all
the things we tell ourselves and
for me
in a way it almost made no sense that i
created a beauty company right and
just the idea of it because i didn't
know anything about it i knew no one in
the industry but every time i get still
like for me um and you know no matter
what people believe whether it's they're
hearing the universe talk to them or god
talk to them like for me i hear it
through my own intuition and my own gut
instinct the idea here is look commit
okay and this is the problem with the
schooling system everything's got to be
figured out first i got to read the
instruction first like nobody really
does read this i never read the answer i
wrote an article about it i don't read
any instructions you know and so
i mean i can't i can't read them because
they're so small
so so uh and even when i could read them
i'm like i don't want to read the
instructions can't they make this
simpler yeah so
and that is the premise there yeah can't
it just be simpler
and the way to make it simple is and we
see this happening today i mean this is
happening on a global scale where
picking a car up now is simple
pick me up it's crazy i don't have to
put the address in it should locate
where i am
car picks me up
i put in the destination tells guy where
to go don't even need to pay for it
either it's already i know that's set up
like simple you guys got everything
should be simplified and the way to
simplify things i remember mercedes benz
years ago i heard about this when they
had first figured out how to put a drop
back a hard top
uh convertible into the trunk they had
never they couldn't figure it out it
used to be these old you know they'd
hang them up in the garage and take them
off and it was like very laborious and
somebody at mercedes-benz said
don't tell me what it's going to cost
tell me when it's done
just get it done no matter what this is
how the elon musk are thinking today you
know this is why apple keeps creating a
crazy product while this will go away
somebody's going to come along one day
and say get rid of the phone
and i still want to communicate yeah and
it'll probably be on a headset more like
this we'll probably we'll probably go in
here right where i'm popping i mean the
watches yeah they're moving there right
it's crazy
so to where i don't even need a watch i
won't need anything it's like okay i
want to call bye-bye we're moving in
that direction of less and faster and
simpler so the way the human being does
that he's in brisbane at this point the
gold coast
i got to get down there he's committed
he doesn't figure he he just gets flight
no research
no no you weren't researching it last
night no not at all if you didn't if you
didn't know about this last night you'd
have been you'd have been doing work
about it last night planning negotiating
with the airlines when you get
compressed on time you got a commitment
you're like i got to be there at 2 30.
everything works out
yeah as i was walking out my assistant
she goes oh where where are you going to
stay
and i was like
booked me a place we're close to you
know
to the park or where you're staying you
won't put that out but um we're on this
trip we went to tokyo
because things don't work out as planned
anyway yeah so i'm not saying go through
life unplanned i have 500 employees
so there's got to be some planning
there's got to be is it stretched over
it doesn't need to be me doing the
planning though yeah
like i need maybe i need somebody else
to do that
i don't have to do that no i just need
to know where i want to go so we were
coming to sydney i knew i had this
commitment with success resources to
come here and do these events good tell
me when the events are bang bang bang
um okay i got to get there right so a
week ago i'm like okay hey lanny i
called my pilot
i want to let route to sydney but
let's stop in hawaii
uh let's go to kauai uh kids have never
been there we'll stay there for three
days acclimate for a second and shoot
down to sydney i had enough data to know
that i would need to do a route like
that storm comes in
i can't get i can't for some reason i
can't get a the place i want in kauai
storm comes across the south the pacific
and
uh lanny said hey we might want to be
careful with this storm coming down
there i said okay well let me just let's
reroute to fiji double storm pops up
double-headed cyclone
okay in our path he's like grant we
can't go that way we'd have to go all
the way around this storm i said no we
don't go to tokyo
now the point of that story is look just
keep moving forward keep moving in a
direction that you want to go to we go
to tokyo i made all these friends in
tokyo i would have never done that but i
was committed to going to sydney
and so again commit move in the
direction that gets you closer to where
you're going to go you know i actually i
spend a bunch of time analyzing and
reflecting on why
it was that we were even able to do it
because
all
like all reasons suggest that we
shouldn't have been able to do it right
because all these other companies had
way more engineering power and um
and and servers and time and money and
all this stuff and i actually think that
this is a pretty instructive thing for
anything that you want to go do because
this is the same property is going to be
true for anything that you guys start is
that someone else is going to have more
resources and be able to do it the
reason why i think we actually ended up
being the ones doing it is because we
just cared way more about it than
everyone else right so
there were always projects at some of
these other companies that were these
hobbies but
we always thought that it was this
really important thing and really just
like felt in our gut in our heart that
we wanted to do it and you know early on
there were always these skeptics saying
that oh this can't be a business we
didn't actually care that much about it
being a business early on uh but a lot
of the reason why bigger companies
didn't invest in it was because it
wasn't clear that there was a model that
would work for it it seemed like a bad
idea yeah and
i actually think that that's true for a
lot of the best ideas where it is that
it's not that someone else can't do it
they actually can and the odds are
stacked against you but i think often
that belief in the fact that you just
care so much about what you're doing is
the only thing that kind of drives you
to do it and you know to be honest that
kind of drives me to this day i mean one
of the the big emphasis uh points for
the company right now
is internet.org and you know for a while
we have this rallying cry of can we
connect a billion people um and you know
when we start talking about that we
thought that was crazy right it was way
bigger than any service in in the world
that had been built and you know it was
10 digits long right it's like you know
it just it felt crazy we'd never get to
that but then the thing is as we started
to actually get closer to that we took a
step back and we're like all right well
our mission isn't actually to get one in
seven people in the world to be
connected it's we want to connect
everyone so it's um it's a big issue
that only around a third of the people
in the world have access to the internet
and that's something that we think that
we can do something about and similar to
early facebook we don't there's no
business model around this i mean all
the people who have all the money in the
world i mean it's not necessarily a fair
thing are already the people who are on
facebook right it's in the first you
know seventh of the world um but we just
believe really strongly it's like this
is what we are here to do um this is
what our company cares about i care
about it the team cares about it our
culture cares about it so we're just
gonna keep pushing on it and i actually
think a lot of the reason why great
stuff gets built is because it's kind of
irrational at the time
but so it kind of selects for the people
who care the most about it doing it
people ask my wife all the time what's
something about tony that nobody knows
and she says the level he prepares so
that was ray dalio i know i got a chance
to be with literally the da vinci of
investing most average people never
heard his name but
you have to have a ten years ago jeff a
five billion dollar net worth and he had
to give him a hundred million to start
with for him to talk to you right today
he won't talk to you and take your money
too much money you have he's he's closed
his fund out he won't he won't do a dime
more so to do that
i i couldn't i couldn't consciously walk
in and just say okay i've read
everything it's available i had to watch
every video there's only a few out there
i had to read every piece i had to like
tear it apart and see if i could
understand his entire structure of
investing so that when i was there i
could ask questions no one else was
asked before and as a result he actually
shared with me he's averaged a 23 return
for 21 straight years
billions and billions and billions of
dollars smartest man one of the smartest
man alive in that area and because i
understood so much we could pitch and
catch you know most people you know you
can just they just they can just throw
the ball right but i need i want to
throw the ball and have you throw it to
me and throw it right back to you right
that's where we get something that's
really exciting and because i prepared
that level he was saying to me after he
goes you know this better than anybody i
know and he's so it opened him up more
and you talked to me in more detail in
the end he actually gave me a strategy
that i said to him i said look i said
ray
i said you're one of the most generous
men i know
i said you've just given me this
incredible strategy but the strategy was
like explaining why most people lose
money and here's how he's made money in
every market right pretty complex
strategy and i said the strategy is
great but it's kind of like you told me
you want to build a chocolate cake get
some chocolate you know get some sugar
you can tell me the amounts i mean the
amounts are everything right you got the
right amounts and he goes tony i can't
give you that that's my secret sauce and
i said ray you can give it to me because
i can't he goes that's my that's why you
know that's why you know i get the money
i do i said no you don't you haven't
taken money for 10 years i said you're
going to give away half your net worth
anyway i said you just got done telling
me the average guy is never going to do
this help me out give me your secret
sauce right and i got him laughing he
goes well tony it's kind of complex i
said i'm going to take complex and
making it simple he goes well i use
leverage i said create one without
leverage so the average guy could do it
right
and then i got this chilled on the back
of my spine when he said well it
wouldn't be perfect i said your idea not
perfect it's better than anybody else on
earth i said right tell me and then i
took out a pen and just said tell me the
numbers right he looked at me goes
well let's try this and he starts to lay
this thing out so when i'm done i can
feel the vibration in my body like i got
something nobody's got that i can give
to the world that'll be extraordinary
and i go he goes go test that he goes
don't when people talk about testing
they look back five years or ten years
he said
but the past doesn't equal the future
that way but if you were to test
something over 75 years the entire
modern time of history that's what you
should test that formula back test it
for 75 years come back tell me what you
get
85 percent of the time it's for 75 years
think of how much the world has changed
the last 10 years or 20 years 85 percent
of the time it makes money the 15 of the
time it didn't
the maximum drawdown in 75 years was not
20 like you've seen at 30 or 40 you've
seen in the marketplace over the years
3.9
the average loss is 1.7 average gain is
10 so if you could go to vegas and you
could be right 85 percent of the time
and when you lost only lose you know one
percent 1.7 percent
how you'd be you'd be investing a little
bit you'd be gambling a little bit right
so he gave that to me so i got those
types of things because i was so
prepared and so when i go to do an
audience a big audience like i do my
date with esti seminar people do 20
pages of homework and i read all that
for a couple thousand people i won't
remember their faces i remember it's in
my brains when somebody stands up
something inside me recognizes the
pattern or recognizing this the pattern
that multiple people in the room need to
deal with and my brain clicks in and
makes it happen so i believe
you know garbage and garbage out as
simplistic as it is that if you keep
putting unbelievable quality amount in
when it's time for you to cash that
spiritual emotional
physical financial business check it
ain't gonna bounce because you've been
making deposits and you have plenty to
give you're not you're not just winging
it to see what happens so i'm intense
about that but i also love it because it
just i'm always growing too because i'm
always learning more than i need to
teach anybody else a lot of people want
to be stars so
the labels are in a position where they
have to and should say no to most people
that come into their door
and they need to be really sure about
you before they sign you
so
they said no to me a lot they said no to
me even the label i'm signed to columbia
sony
uh turned me down
you know
like a year or so before i got signed
so
it just shows you that you have to be
persistent
you have to
keep trying to get better
learn from your criticisms and
uh
and and then uh
just
play to win and uh that's what that's
what i was doing how do i define success
let me tell you money's pretty nice
i'm not gonna stand up here and tell you
that it's not about money because money
is very nice
i like money
it's good for buying things
but having a lot of money does not
automatically
make you a successful person
what you want
is money
and meaning
you want your work to be meaningful
because meaning is what brings the real
richness to your life
what you really want
is to be surrounded by people you trust
and treasure and by people who cherish
you
that's when you're really rich life is
short life should be fun and it should
be fun not you know it should be if if
the the chairman of the company's having
fun you know if you go to a party and
you know if i let my hair down and i'm
the first to be thrown in the swimming
pool and uh and i'm not just sitting
standing in the corner of the room
sipping sherry or something then
everybody will have a laugh and
everybody have it fun you know if your
gemini company be the first to dance on
the table you know just get everybody
else up dancing on the table and make
sure the parties you know the parties
are laughed so
uh you know so play hard and uh play
hard work hard and then uh and you know
follow certain principles in life you
know be you know
you know love people make make sure you
make a positive difference in this world
while you're on it this work-life
harmony thing is what i try to teach
young employees actually and senior
executives at amazon too but especially
the people coming i get we're asked
about work life balance all the time
and my view is that's a debilitating
phrase
because
it
it implies there's a strict trade-off
and the reality is if i'm happy at home
i come into the office with tremendous
energy and if i'm happy at work i come
home with tremendous energy and so it
actually is a circle it's not a balance
and
and i think that that is uh
is worth everybody paying attention to
you want to have you never want to be
that guy and we all know we all have a
co-worker
who is that person who as soon as they
come into the meeting they drain all of
the energy out of the room
you can just feel the energy level go
that you don't want to be that guy so
you want to come into the office and
give everybody a kick in their step
certainly during the time i was at
harvard
i wasn't sure what i was going to do
the idea that software was this field
that uh
was the opportunity was
unbelievable that became more obvious
during the three-year period i was here
but my dad had been a lawyer
i thought of mathematics you know like
doing well in the platinum that was the
coolest thing uh and the computer
software
i didn't think those people were as
smart as the math people so it's like
well am i going to go into the easy
field
or this really hard field but uh
anyway math uh was fantastic when i
finally picked
and decided to go go do microsoft then i
got into a period
from age uh
19 uh to about
40 where i wasn't able to
look at the latest on you know how
tornadoes work or how mitochondria work
i was pretty monomaniacal
and when i was able to ask steve this is
the year 2000 c balmer
uh he he mistakenly graduated uh but
then he started it stan
but i was trying to hire him but his
parents told him you're supposed to
graduate which was fine but then he
started at stanford business school and
he was in his first year and i thought
this is perfect i'll get him to drop out
of stanford business school uh so in a
certain sense he is a dropout uh
and he was very key to the success of
microsoft i mean
uh
he knew a lot of things but during that
period i didn't get to do much at
harvard
you know i took all these courses
because it was just so amazing that
people were interested in talking about
them and uh
i i have to say
i never went to a lecture during reading
period or any anything because the
courses that i was actually signed up
for i finally started to work on those
uh so i was in halal the minute would
open to the minute it would close during
reading period trying to catch up on on
that other set of courses so people say
i'm a dropout which is literally true
but because i like college courses the
online college courses there's a company
called the learning company that i buy
uh tons and tons of their stuff and i do
you know at least four or five courses a
year
in a sense i like uh going to college
more than anyone uh so
i've sort of made sure my job certainly
post-microsoft
uh that i get to spend my time meeting
with scientists learning new things you
know seeing what the hard problems are
in some cases giving money to people to
take on
uh
those very very hard problems when you
kind of look back now what would you say
are the traits that what you know when
you do look back that you needed to kind
of turn your life around
you you need to know you need to you
need to under you need to be honest with
yourself right like like i am i am
brutally
honest with
and maybe why the people in in the uk
like me
like i just tell the truth to myself
okay and the fact that whether other
people can handle it or not it's up to
them
money is important
if you're broke you're
selfish if you're broken you're even
more selfish
uh anybody can make it
no matter what your troubles are how you
what side what side of town or city the
city you were born in what class you
were born into if you want out and
you're not and you're not going to make
excuses about how to get out
um
then you can do it
if i can do it anybody can do it like
today we i have 2 billion worth of real
estate today
one deal at a time putting one deal like
that is an amazing
feat for anyone but for someone that
came from where i'm at
no credit when i was 25
nobody's taught me really how to do any
of this stuff
but once you make a decision you got to
make the decision you got to make a
decision not to be comfortable you got
to make a decision and say look i want
to have so much
that i can take care of not just myself
and my family my two kids and my wife i
can take care of communities
and that's what i've always wanted i
always wanted to be a hero dude
i'd watch batman superman
wonder woman you you you know i read
those cartoon books and i'm like i want
to be the hero
and um and i think it's important that
people
understand they can be the hero i mean
you almost have to have that drive like
in other words you can't fake it you
can't like pretend that you want to read
about ted turner and okay i'll skip one
movie
your soul yeah i mean you can fake it to
make it in a lot of areas particularly
if you're working for somebody else but
at the end of the day
um
if you're going to be
created something you've got to make the
effort to be great at something um
whether it's sports whether it's physics
math science business whatever it may be
you know it's not just a natural skill
you've got you've got to
to learn and particularly if you're in
the technology industry because it
changes every day you know
when i got started in in
you know after i got i got it i was a
bartender when i first came to dallas
got into the pc industry got fired
started my own company but
there i learned early on that there was
always something new and most people
didn't put in the time to learn it it's
like now with artificial intelligence
lots of people talk about artificial
intelligence lots of people talk about
machine learning and neural networks not
a lot of people are putting in the time
to take classes or do the tutorials or
to to learn how to apply it to business
and that's what it takes and and you
know that's just something i've always
enjoyed so that i've been fortunate in
that if you study people who are at the
pinnacle of anything
you recognize that to get there
motivation was maybe one percent of the
formula maybe
one percent
and i'll prove it to you
if you want to become a world-class
bodybuilder say an ifbb pro
what that takes is you have to train
twice a day
six days a week
you have to have eight meals a day your
calorie intake is regimented your meals
are pre-planned and pre-cooked
you don't eat according to taste you eat
according to function
so my trainer for instance will eat and
i'm going what are you eating
and he's having the most he'll have
chicken that was boiled without salt
and he'll have like half a kilo of it
and what are you doing
he says i'm taking in protein he doesn't
say i'm eating he says i'm taking in
protein for him it's functional it's not
taste based
then
you will probably have to train for a
minimum and this is if you are a genetic
phenom
you'd have to train for a minimum of 10
years
before you could get on a stage
and compete at an average level with an
average global bodybuilder average
okay
so why am i say why am i telling you
this
all all of us here at the beginning of a
new year write these things called new
year's resolutions
and then it you you know you new year's
resolutions number one make more money
yeah
uh number two
uh change my boyfriend
number three get into shape
yeah number three
get into shape is somewhere in the top
three
so what do you do you go to the gym you
get a gym membership
yep
you buy you go to the local uh nike
store and you buy like all of your gym
gear
you are motivated you are inspired you
are going to the damn gym
you go to youtube you subscribe to all
of the fitness channels you go to
instagram you follow all of the fitness
models you are motivated you are going
to the damn gym you're going to get in
shape that's what you're going to do
the people you're following on youtube
have been working on for a minimum of
five years to look like that
so you have the incorrect understanding
that after a month of working out you're
going to look like them
so what happens in the first month
you're excited you go to gym every
single month
you know and you take the pains and your
body is sore but you know i'm excited
i'm going to gym then life happens
company doesn't make money you don't
make your targets you fall a bit ill
something happens and all of a sudden
you stop going to gym for a day a day
becomes two two becomes a week now all
of a sudden you've had a gym membership
for three months and you haven't been in
that time
what did you miss you thought motivation
was the formula winners don't need
motivation winners need discipline
discipline's about getting it done
because it needs to get done not because
i feel like it
not because i'm motivated for it
you think nelson mandela is motivated to
spend 27 years in prison
do you think martin luther king was
motivated to march across the states and
proclaim freedom
do you think you know if you look at
people to change the world they're not
doing it because they're motivated
they're doing it because they made a
commitment to do it and they disciplined
to see it through
discipline is far more important than
motivation which is why you got to be
careful the decisions you make because
once you make the decision you have to
see that decision through
like my mentor says first we make the
decisions then the decisions make us
so got to be very careful the decisions
you make be very careful the commitments
you make
motivation i'm telling you now is
completely overrated
it's important don't get me wrong
you know we meet according to motivation
we feel good rah-rah
but that'll fade
you need a stronger will
and a deeper commitment to see things
through the most powerful way
and the easiest way to change your
thermostat setting is by adding people
to your circle
very close proximity that live at a
higher temperature in that area than you
do for example in your faith let's just
say you're a 75 degree or in your faith
you've already seen this you can't
possibly begin to regularly associate
with good godly people who pray
regularly who try to live righteously
and there are 110 120 degrees of of
faith in their life and not have that
proximity heat you up now you won't get
to where they are you'll get to
somewhere between where you are at 75
degrees and they are at 110 over time
you become 100 degree and you alter the
thermostat setting through association
same in business if you and i were to
hang around each other every single day
and let's say you were a 75 degree or in
business hypothetically and i don't know
that about you but let's just say you
were
and i was 150 degree and we hung around
each other all the time don't you think
through that association especially if
you had two or three or four people like
me in your life that just over time you
don't even feel it you're at 80 you're
85 you're at 90 you're at 95 and that's
where you are we understand the power of
this with our children
because we know at school the teachers
have influence over them they're mentors
but the people that really have
influence over our children are for
their friends because they're around
them all the time and so we know it sets
their temperature this is true in
fitness if you're a 75 degree of fitness
at every meal every day at the gym all
your associations hypothetically
speaking where with someone who was
shredded and fit the way you wanted to
look at 150 degrees you know over time
you get heated up and so you can't be
with someone every day you can't be with
them all the time but the key is to get
more proximity in the areas that matter
with people whose thermostat setting is
higher than yours i am a product you are
listening to me right now because i've
been so obsessed with this concept of
adding new associations to my life that
live in the areas that i want to improve
in at higher temperatures than me it's
my obsession to this day i'll give you a
secret one of the reasons i even do my
show is i know that i'm influencing many
of these guests in the areas that matter
most to them through our proximity and
in some cases they do it for me and so
i'm obsessed with the power of
association but i don't just associate
see
all personnel says yeah you're the five
people you hang around
kinda
you really are the five to ten people
you hang around if you're conscious all
the time
of studying them of observing them of
asking questions of the fact that you
should be altering your thermostat
setting that's when it really moves it's
not just hanging around it's consciously
and intentionally spending time with
people
where you allow it to impact you where
you study them where you really observe
them where you're open to their
influence there has to be a level of
trust before you can do that where you
surrender yourself to them but it's not
just being around them it's
intentionally being around people that
alters that thermostat setting so power
of association is the main way to do it
i was at the treasury i didn't really
ever think i'd live in california but
from the point of view of the us
treasury all the exciting stuff was
happening out here in these companies
that didn't exist and so i wanted to
work in silicon valley
um but it was actually hard it was 2000
2000 2001.
lots of people said i would never hire
anyone like you to my face
there was a huge bust the tech first
tech bubble had just burst
and so it was actually hard to get a job
and when i finally got one at google it
felt like the wrong job i had a
spreadsheet some of you have those it
had my criteria for my jobs
and the problem with the google job is
other than loving the company it met
none of the criteria i was a business
unit general manager but you know i'm
not that dumb there were no business
units so that didn't job title didn't
mean anything
it was also a couple levels lower
than other job offers i had elsewhere
and eric did he put his hand on my
little spreadsheet when i showed him my
criteria and how google met none of it
except that i loved the company
and said you love the mission
this is a rocket ship when you get
offered a seat on the rocket ship you
don't ask what seat
and this is one of the most common
career mistakes i see people make all
the time i'll have someone coming out of
government or someone who's in legal or
someone who's in marketing and they want
to change careers
they want to move from marketing to
sales it's not hard maybe it's not a
good example from legal to marketing or
from politics or industries and then
you'll say okay we're willing to take a
chance on you you'll start here and
they're like but that's three levels
lower or two years behind
and i'm looking at them i'm like if
you're going to work for the next 40
years why do you care get yourself and
the job i took at google and the job i
took at facebook were more junior than
every other job offer i had right
but they turned out to be much bigger
opportunities we both grew up in tacoma
and there used to be a thing called
toastmasters i don't know if you
remember toastmasters but toastmasters
was a local regional and a national
speaking group for anybody that wanted
to get better at speaking
well my dad had gone to a toastmasters
early on and heard one of the most
successful magazine entrepreneurs in the
world speak he comes back and tells me i
just had a chance to hear one of the
most successful magazine entrepreneurs
in the world
speak and he said when are you taking
your s.a.t i said i'm taking it next
year he said well this guy was failing
out of high school
he was struggling he was raised by a
single mom in the midwest but he
promised his mother he would take a test
called the s.a.t
so he takes the s.a.t in may's junior
year doesn't expect anything get to
score back in june now the s.a.t which i
don't know how many your population know
but it's it's a standardized test with
the math part and a verbal part both are
scored out of 800 points well this guy
takes it he's bombing he's failing out
of school he doesn't expect anything as
he's telling the story of toastmasters
well he gets a 1480 out of 1600.
so he's stunned right that would be for
the smart people that listened to your
problem yeah right cognitive dissonance
i got a 900 on my sats just to give
people a friend right and i got a 10 90
and i got a 10 10 right i was just hey
four digits it was a miracle right and
and but it's a hard test and it you you
know it's a variety of different things
so he gets the score and his mother
doing what any mother would do knowing
her kids says did you cheat right she
knows her son and he said i swear to god
i tried to cheat but the way the numbers
were and the scantrons and the bubbles
you couldn't cheat so she says you mean
to tell me you really got that score he
said yeah i got the score so he's
stunned tom so as my dad telling me the
story i'm like okay so he says all right
so what he decides is because he
realizes he's smart and he's going into
his senior year he says i'm going to go
to class
now he starts to go to class he doesn't
hang out with who he did when he didn't
go to class
all right teacher see him in class and
they said hey maybe franklin pierce
maybe we missed the boat on this kid so
they start to treat him differently well
as the guy would tell the story he
graduates goes to a community college
goes on to wichita state goes under the
ivy league and becomes this massively
successful magazine entrepreneur so i
said okay well the guy was always smart
he just needed a standardized test to
unlock it my dad said no that's not the
story and this is what i want you to
understand
he said 12 years after all this guy's
success he gets a letter in the mail
from princeton new jersey doesn't think
anything about it the next day his wife
says you're going to open it he opens it
true story turns out the s.a.t board
will periodically review their test
taking procedures and the policies the
year he took the test he was one of 13
people
sent the wrong s.a.t score
his actual score was a 740 out of 1600.
and he said people think my whole life
changed when i got to 1480. but what
happened my whole life changed when i
started acting like a 1480 and what does
a 1480 do he goes to class
well this is one of the first stories i
would share when i had my opportunity at
alabama or florida state or georgia so a
your language is powerful but number two
your behavior is way ahead of your
success
and so many people let their feelings
dictate what they do as opposed to throw
your behavior out there russell wilson's
510 he shouldn't be playing pro football
but he behaves like the best quarterback
in the country and he's done that since
before he was at that level and then his
feelings and emotions and his skill
caught up to that behavior i think the
lesson my dad was trying to teach me
ultimately was in addition to my
language what i do
not how i feel about my past is going to
determine who i am in the future and
that's what i think neutral thinking is
and i think neutral thinking isn't just
thinking i think it's behavior and i
think it's language and so your behavior
is what's going to change you but
you also have to start by asking
yourself what do i want and why do i
want it why don't i have it
you know what am i willing to do to get
it i think the media there's a little
bit of this cultural bias towards
thinking that you know one person does
this right i mean people say that you
know i built facebook or steve jobs
built apple or whatever but you know
that's really not true right i mean it's
we're we're people we we helped uh but
there were thousands and thousands of
other people involved in building these
things and the reality is is that as
strong as any one individual is
no one person can deal with all the
challenges that are going to get thrown
at them in anything that you do and
one of the ways that i think we maintain
resilience is by having
co-founders and partners who
complement our strengths and
fortify our weaknesses and can kind of
encourage us and give us a push to to
keep going when things are tough and
there's actually a lot of data on this
that suggests that companies that get
started with more co-founders are more
likely to be successful and it isn't
quite clear
exactly from that data why that's the
case although it is very clear in terms
of the outcome for the startups that it
is the case um but i would guess
that the reason why that's the case is
because of this resilience point where
people who start something by themselves
i i just think like there's no way that
any one person can overcome all of the
different things that you need to do to
to build a startup or take on any kind
of other project in the world but if you
have two or three or four partners then
i don't know i mean maybe over time one
of them
doesn't like it and drops out but you
still have enough strength on the team
to power through all the challenges that
you have and that's kind of how you go
and you know at facebook today one of
the things that i always find a little
bit
funny is again that so much attention is
placed on on me as the person running
the company whereas i think you know
people like cheryl um who really you
know is my partner running the whole
business or you know folks like chris
cox who run a huge amount of our product
or
mike schrepfer who's our chief
technology officer and and kind of make
sure that a ton of uh what we're doing
works or jay parikh who you know runs
all of our global infrastructure and in
all the data centers around the world
we couldn't make facebook work without
those people right and and there were
really hard days where where i'm not
sure what to do next and
and they keep me going first goal
in any conversation which you must do
you must
get into immediate
i'm gonna use a word it's a big word
we've all heard before it's called raw
rapport
with the straight line
the first thing you're gonna learn to do
using tonality and certain words we'll
go through this afternoon you're gonna
learn how to get into immediate rapport
on both a conscious
and
an unconscious level conscious so yeah
wow it makes sense to them
and unconsciously like i just kind of
like that guy i can't tell you exactly
why but he sounds sharp it sounds like a
winner
you need to get into
instant rapport immediate rapport on
both the conscious and unconscious level
so
you can then open them up
to being essentially what's called
qualified
so you can actually find out
and in the straight line qualifying is
about not just what their needs are
it's their needs
what any pain they have in they might
have
okay we gather intelligence we don't
just identify needs we gather
intelligence
you do that by getting into rapport with
someone first it's not like let me
gather intelligence first and then get
into rapport the first thing you need to
do using tonality in certain words we're
going to learn how to do it is to get
into immediate rapport
and then use that rapport
to gather intelligence and move them
down the straight line uncertainty is
not predictable but it's preparable and
i don't actually think that's a word but
here's what i mean
what i know for sure and this relates to
everybody is that your life is of course
going to be full of a lot of joy and
amazing things and breathtaking moments
and rapturous moments of of ecstasy
right but it's also going to be riddled
with moments of
unexpected uncertainty and chaos joy is
much easier to handle you just kind of
let go and go with it right the good
times you have not a lot of action or
thought required but uncertainty and
chaos require a real rigid set of
principles and for me those principles
over the last 12 months have become
acceptance optimism and action and these
three principles have a real linear
connection to the outcome you're seeking
without acceptance when bad things
happen
there's no optimism without optimism
there's no action and without action
there's often no victory or at least
victory is delayed and hard times are
elongated so when bad news visits
whether that's being unexpectedly fired
from your job or dumped by your partner
evicted by your landlord or losing a
loved one in the case of a pandemic you
have to do everything you can to stick
to these principles despite the intense
cloud of natural emotions that will try
to convince you and me otherwise and you
know like i do
a lot of sort of introspective thinking
for a living and even i am not
immune from letting emotion get the best
of me in times of intense chaos i like
no matter how much i've read or written
in my diary or how many podcasts i've
done even i
fall victim especially in the short term
to all of those emotions and sometimes
to the the instructions those emotions
give you which will lead you to um
to pretty dire outcomes so you know you
get dumped by your partner you
immediately think revenge right you get
fired by your boss you think um you know
i'm gonna sue them right i fall for
those traps too and i don't think i
don't necessarily think it's
the aim of all humans should be to try
and avoid those emotions and that
thinking because i think it's quite
impossible but it's to be better at the
response right to shorten the time that
those emotions sit with you and to be
better in your reaction and i want to
clarify that acceptance when i talk
about acceptance it doesn't mean being
emotionless it can often mean the exact
opposite you have to accept how you're
feeling except what's happened
and importantly retire from trying to
change the unchangeable or from
wallowing in regret and you have to do
everything you can to get yourself to a
place of optimism i see that as your
responsibility people won't like me
saying that right people typically
especially in hard times don't like to
delegate responsibility to themselves so
as hard as it can be you have to find
and create hope for yourself and have
faith just like everything else has in
your life that this too shall pass you
are capable of more i just want to tell
you to remind you that you are capable
of more that this struggle that's in
front of you right now that seems
all-encompassing and impossible to
overcome it's not your max
you can handle it because if this is
your max then you don't grow and you
don't become the person that you know
you're capable of becoming
this video will help so the most pain i
went through was when i was on my tour
last year and i broke my neck i broke my
neck i i fainted and and hit my head on
the wall and and broke my neck in two
spots i compressed my spine i had a
concussion which i've never had in my
life before and i had to they put me in
a neck brace they put me in these and i
wore this one for
50 days or so and this one for 10 or
something like that it was 60 days of of
wearing something like this
and
only be able to take it off for 10
minutes a day
that's it so i had to sleep in this i
had to have the shower in this i had to
do my speaking gigs and this and you can
see i don't know if you can see this
duct tape on here
because this one was more comfortable
than this one
and so like i really didn't want to
break this one but just from use right
from having it on all day long
eventually it broke and my wife taped it
up and she wrote here i love you get
well soon love nina kind of like a cast
anyway this is the most painful thing
that i had to go through and the day i
broke my neck i was supposed to be doing
my speaking gig in in colorado and we
had to cancel that because obviously i
can't do it while i'm in the hospital
but then
came a really important time
what do i do next i don't know how
long a concussion lasts i don't know how
i'm going to deal with the pain i
haven't really broken a bone in my body
before let alone two in my neck i didn't
know how safe it was to travel still did
my speaking gigs and the advice was rest
and go home you can't get on a plane
because of the compression but just just
drive home just rest and go home
and you know my agent wanted me to do it
the doctors want me to do it like i'm
not going to go home i don't want to go
home
this is my chance to show myself what
i'm made of this is my chance to see
what i can do i'll let me at least try
let me at least try and it's very rare
that we actually get pushed to our
limits like our actual limits your push
to your physical limits and you can't do
anything more and so my initial thought
was well forget that i mean let's just
everybody who was supposed to come let's
just do something tomorrow
this is what i was thinking let's do
something tomorrow in our airbnb
and just have them come over and i'll
lie down on the couch or the bed and
they can ask me questions
i'm here to give value guys i'm here to
help let's go helping entrepreneurs is
going to be healing for me and the
doctor like yeah you can't do that you
got a concussion you can't even think
clearly or properly like that's never
going to happen so i had to refund
everybody in colorado and um and my next
stop was kansas city
and we drove to kansas city not too far
away and
i was still
feeling the massive pain from the
from the neck
but still the concussion i hadn't
recovered from my concussion and i
didn't know how long it was going to
last and i made a video
for the people who bought tickets in
kansas city canceling on them
and what i wanted to do was say hey i'm
here anyway
i'll give you your money back come to
the hotel
and i'll i'll still talk to you for as
long as i can go and it was the morning
the day before in the morning i was
making a video i thought
i couldn't even finish making a video
i started getting dizzy halfway through
the video and so i i paused it and i
thought okay we should just we should
just cancel this like i i can't even get
through
uh two minutes of making a video
and so i tried again at night and i got
through the video and i said you know
what i don't know how long i'm gonna
last tomorrow i already booked the hotel
you know i'm not it's not it's
non-refundable for me uh you guys
already booked your tickets you booked
the time off in your calendar i'm going
to refund you the money because i'm not
going to go for four hours like i've
been doing in each city but
i'll go for as long as i can
if you want to show up and and i'll try
to help and i went
for an hour and a half
and it was the greatest hour and a half
you know one of the greatest hour and a
half of my life and and my wife had to
then pull me off after an hour and a
half because i certainly get i don't
even notice it but i certainly get you
know woozy on stage
and um it was great i was so pumped
because this was this was i'm done i've
never been pulled off a stage before
and here i was at my max
and i love the idea of pushing through
the pain obviously be healthy obviously
don't be stupid
but a lot of times we pull ourselves
back way too soon we don't allow
ourselves to actually test what we're
made of to see how far we could actually
go
and so i kept these thanks to my friend
mark draker i don't collect things um i
don't i don't have souvenirs of stuff
but he said you need to collect you need
to save them as a souvenir of what
happened as a memento like all right
whatever i'll keep it and i look at this
i'm like i'm crazy i did that
60 days in this and kept going on tour
and we still did 10 more cities and i i
sat at the front of these stages
sitting down because i couldn't stand
properly and i had had like two or three
pillows behind me and an ice pack over
my right shoulder the whole time and and
still spoke for three to four hours
every day right
i still made videos you can go back on
my channel and you'll see me wearing
this with like this giant scab or scar
in my head because this is where i hit
my head on the wall
it's crazy this is a reminder of what
i'm capable of that whatever max i feel
like i'm facing right now is not my max
and i think you're capable of more as
well you want to make something
beautiful i mean
you want to
trigger whatever
fundamental aesthetic algorithms are
like like in your brain there's
you have i think some
intrinsic uh elements that that
represent beauty um and
and that that trigger
the emotion of appreciation of beauty in
in your in your mind
um
and i think that these are
these are actually relatively
consistent among people i mean not not
completely um some people like if not
everyone likes the same thing but there
are there's a lot of commonality but i
think it is important to
to combine
aesthetic design with functionality like
the thing that's like if you say like
what was really hard about say the model
s or the model x
was to
combine aesthetics and
utility
so to balance the two
um you can make a car look very good by
giving it
sort of
certain proportions like making it sort
of low and slim
and and
but
if you uh if you do that the utility is
significantly affected to make a sports
car look good is relatively easy
but to make a sedan look good or an suv
look good is quite difficult really pay
attention to the little details
the
the nuances of of design and shape and
form function and
um
that you know just the way it looks in
different lights and when something's
off the little thing how do you
experience that
it drives me bananas
yeah
um i mean it's and it does the problem
is like if you
you can train yourself to to pay
attention to the tiny details i think
almost anyone can
um
although it it this is a very much
double-edged sword because then you see
all the little details
um and then little things drive you
crazy
so
but like most people don't they don't
see they don't consciously see the small
details but they
they do subconsciously see them like you
you sort of your mind takes in a result
of the overall
you know
an overall impression
and you you know if something is
appealing or not even though you may not
be able to
point out exactly why
um and it's it's the summation of these
many small details
so most of us experience it as a oh i
think that's ugly or i think that's
beautiful or like wow that's elegant but
yeah can't break it down you mentioned
something in passing like you can train
yourself in this though yeah you can
train yourself i think
you can make yourself
pay attention to to why
um you're essentially
bring the
subconscious awareness into conscious
awareness
god i wish i could do that how do you do
that
just just pay really close attention
almost like a meditation on the object
and trying to find the details like why
do i not like this is that what yeah
just look look closely and carefully
there's no doubt that the anti-trust
lawsuit was bad for microsoft and
if
we would have been more focused on
creating the uh
phone operating system and so instead of
using android today you would be using
windows mobile if it hadn't been for the
honor trust case uh microsoft would go
oh we were so close we we you know i was
just too distracted i screwed that up uh
because of the distraction and you know
we were just three months too late with
the release that motorola would have
used on a phone uh
so yes uh it's a winner take all game
that is for sure that you know now
nobody here's ever heard of windows
mobile
but oh well
and i wouldn't uh
that's a few hundred billion here or
there
i wouldn't have retired as soon and that
one is less you know i am disappointed
that windows mobile didn't succeed but
in terms of uh my own life
you know even though it was a very
painful thing because i got very
personally involved in the defense of
the company the fact that i retired
earlier probably net was good for me
because i got down the learning curve on
the foundation i got to partner with
melinda in the early days of the
foundation
and you know i don't have a life where
i'm allowed to complain uh because
basically you know only 99 of things
have worked out very very well i believe
that uh the
primary success factor for amazon.com
has been an obsession over the customer
and a focus on customer service this is
clearly important in any business but
especially important online and the
reason for this is that word of mouth is
incredibly powerful online
if you make a customer unhappy on the
internet they won't tell five friends
they will tell 5 000 friends on usnet
news groups and list serves and so on
likewise of course if you can make a
customer happy by meeting or exceeding
their expectations they can also tell
five thousand people and therefore you
know be evangelists for you they can use
the internet as a megaphone
so it's very important to do the things
that you actually are going to claim to
do and
what this means basically is the balance
of power has shifted away from the
merchant and toward the consumer which
is a great thing i think for everybody
involved it's even great for the
merchant as long as the merchant
realizes it well you know i managed to
get here steadman and i have
absolutely uh differing philosophies
because he um teaches
um the idea of he has a book called um
not yeah what is a book called
the book is called you can make it
happen nine steps to success and he's
always um talking to me about cr having
a vision that would with no vision that
people perish and i always say i don't
have a vision i don't have a vision to
get here to where i am my vision was of
surrendering to what i believe is was
god's vision for me and i always say god
can dream a bigger dream for you that
you can dream for yourself i now believe
that i need a vision i think stedman is
finally right that in order to continue
to move forward that i need to develop a
vision for myself and
one of my big goals is to use this
television show as a forum
and a catalyst for change in people's
lives that's one of them yes the other
is to move out into the world in a more
um
uh
impactful global format to help women
and children across the globe without
education the people perish without
education
nobody will be able to survive without
education women cannot overcome poverty
will not be able to learn to take care
of themselves will not be able to move
forward on the planet so i want to use
my life and this television show to
continue to do that i honestly just
don't think about mistakes but let me
see if i can try them in i i just like
to if i make a mistake i put it behind
me and i just move move move forward but
um
um but
um
but uh
you know and and you know yes i've you
know i mean there have been you know
music musical bands that i've missed
trying to sign like dars straights um
uh you know there have been companies
that have fallen flat in their face like
virgin kohler
um
uh
you know but
uh uh
you know but
you know that's just part of that's just
part of um
uh you know being an entrepreneur you
you're gonna have these things happening
all the time so i don't really see them
as mistakes they're just um you know
they're just
uh
you know if you're an entrepreneur
you know that some things are not going
to go right something isn't going to go
right what do we got there tell us a bit
more about the book that you've brought
with you oh the actual man this is
absolutely this is the book that
everybody knows about where did that
come from 10x
this this was after the collapse
uh i was working hard
and i kept telling elena what am i doing
wrong
i think a lot of people have this
conversation like what am i doing wrong
i'm working hard
i'm take care of my customers
i'm fair to everybody and i can't get
ahead why can't i get my break i'm a
talented guy
i'm working hard i'm talented i'm
working hard i'm tired like it was like
this like and i cannot get i can't punch
through
and then i saw a lot of people that were
less talented
not taking care of their customers
didn't have as good a product that were
just
flying
and so i sat down every book i've ever
written except for one
was about
me trying to solve a problem for me and
the 10x rule i didn't know it was going
to be the 10x rule when i finished it
until until i finished it
it was about hey why am i working so
hard not getting ahead and the whole the
premise of this book is my my multiplier
was broken i wasn't multiplying i was
adding
i was doing a little bit more
i was never doing a lot more
i was never doing enough more
to to expand so that i wasn't a slave to
my business when you're feeling
gratitude and your heart is open you're
broadcasting energy into the field now
frequency the frequency you lay the
intent of the thought of your health or
your wealth that frequency can carry the
thought of your wealth it can carry the
thought of your health if you're
suffering
you can't the suffering does not carry
that energy does not carry the thought
of your wealth it carries a different
set of thoughts so then so then we're
teaching people
how to self-regulate because if you're
going to believe in that future that
you're imagining with all of your heart
it better be open and activated and you
better know how to self-regulate and you
have to know the moment you disconnect
from the energy of your future because
of some circumstance in your life and
you lose that feeling
if you're practicing it on a daily basis
with your eyes closed then the next
level is to be able to open your eyes
and do it right in the moment and be
able to self-regulate and change
the the frustration from some experience
in your life back to the energy of your
future now
that requires great awareness and great
effort but if you have a community of
people
that are practicing this on a daily
basis and they're connected to their
future because that's where
their mind is
they begin to want the future
more than the emotions of the past so
we've done enough measurements now lewis
to know that we can teach people how to
do that and we have evidence that people
can sustain it for 45 minutes to an hour
it's a skill now they know that they
know how to do it so now they have brain
coherence and heart coherence well once
the heart begins to become orderly and
coherent it acts as an amplifier and it
drives energy to the brain so now the
brain is getting more energy once the
heart is open and then you're thinking
different set of thoughts and those
thoughts produce different chemicals for
you to feel more of that and here comes
uh nitric oxide from oxytocin and then
all of a sudden your heart literally
starts to swell it literally begins to
open up and there's more energy going
there and now you're coming from a
different level of mind in your book you
talk about something i thought was so
interesting to set the faucet to a
certain drip rate and do nothing but
focus on the dripping of the faucet for
like seven minutes or something the idea
is to pay attention to something which
has no relevance to you
see people are
have divided the universe
this is important this is not important
this person is important for me this
person is not important this is
important for me that's not important
for me you divided the universe you will
never know anything this way
indiscriminate focus indiscriminate
attention
i am not attending to you because you
are somebody with a cobra in your heart
all right it doesn't matter who i speak
to who i am with i'm the same way
indiscriminate
only when your attention and involvement
is indiscriminate
does the universe open up to you
you have discriminated
naturally you close you know people come
to me and say sadhguru i want to walk
the spiritual path
i say okay
be here for three days
let's see what we can do so no such day
after tomorrow my uncle's daughter's
birthday i have to go
oh you want to get enlightened
and day after tomorrow uncle's
daughter's birthday also all right
we got one and a half days
you do one thing you do this this and
this i said sakura but i don't like this
all right i'll give them a small piece
of paper
and say okay write down things that you
like we'll do only do that
you won't believe it in this entire
universe most people like only three or
four things
when
you're so constipated in your head
that you lack only three or four people
or three or four things in your life how
do you want to open up to the existence
because life is happening because of its
openness
this is a fundamental difference between
death and life is
people are thinking it's just breath all
right on one level that is also openness
whether you allow this to happen or you
don't allow it to happen
whether you did it consciously or
unconsciously but it's happening isn't
it openness is on every subatomic
particle is in communication with
everything that's why this is going on
breath is happening so much is happening
in connection with everything it is only
in openness you're alive
as you close doors you're dying in
installments
dying in installments is torture
see
life is fantastic if you're alive and
fully alive
if you're dead it's good at least the
neighbors may think so
this may sound very
not so compassionate but i'm saying
everybody dies you and me will die all
right
if you're dead if the game is over
but if you're half dead
oh
this is endless torture to yourself when
you are being tortured of course you'll
share it with everybody else just being
honest even when it sucks because let me
tell you how many times it's going to be
where if you just lied
oh god it would be so much easier and
you would probably get away with it and
but it the way that i explain lying to
people is you get away with it 50 of the
time and so it tempts you to think it's
a good strategy
but the other fifty percent of the time
it is cratering trust
and once you can't trust the person all
hope is lost
and there's nothing more beautiful than
being in a relationship with somebody
who makes you feel like they're your
number they're number one
and that you totally trust them and lisa
wrote this um instagram post about how
she could see a photo of me with my arm
around a woman or resting my head on a
woman or hugging her or whatever and she
it wouldn't even make her radar to
question it
so
that's the fun for us is having that
level of trust now it's like i think
it's buffett that said you spend your
entire life building your reputation
only takes five seconds to lose it so
it's like we're so careful we for 18
years we've been earning trust with each
other so like dude so especially when i
was back at quest and
it was women would come and flirt and
hit on me because they wanted something
wanted to be sponsored by the company or
whatever and i was around bikini literal
bikini models like all the time
and so if ever there was going to be a
moment of insecurity for my wife it
would have been that period
a she wasn't insecure and b i the
thought of throwing away 18 years of
shared experience of all that trust and
everything it's sex is like rad and
super exciting and i love it the most
but like compared to what i would have
to give up for something like that it
just doesn't rate on the radar so
and by the way thing something like i'm
saying now which most people would hide
from their spouse oh that yeah of course
i find other people attracted what are
you talking about like we just openly
talk about that like she'll nudge me and
be like oh my god don't you think she's
hot
it's like that's just
we set up early on in the relationship
to be aggressively ourselves and one
thing that we both were really honest
about was i was like look it is human
nature you are going to find other guys
attractive and i will actually trust you
more if you
admit when you find somebody attractive
than if you say something stupid like i
only have eyes for you oh really you're
the only human in all of history to like
uh you know transcend their human nature
like it doesn't make sense yeah and then
that's a super fragile place to be
because what happens if i get older what
happens if i get injured or scarred like
then i'm really supposed to believe that
suddenly you're more attracted to
somebody with a scar than somebody
without like it doesn't make sense so we
all live in this fragile bubble of well
as long as they lie to me it's okay and
as long as i'm willing to believe and
even though secretly i know it's a lie
and then it's the more pious than now
like oh my god she's thinking all these
nice things about me but i'm actually
finding other people attractive and i'm
just lying about it and so then you're
like wait if i'm lying about it is she
lying about it and so it just
it erodes all that trust so from the
jump we were like look you're going to
find other people attractive i'm going
to find other people attractive but let
me introduce you to this magical word
called commitment
now i'm with you because i love you
because i respect you
but i'm also with you because i'm
committed to you and so you don't have
to worry that i'm going to be looking
over my shoulder for a more attractive
woman there are going to be more
attractive women than you for sure
especially as you age
who the [ __ ] cares you're my wife
we have shared an experience we've
shared a life we've built this around
each other and commitment means
something to me going back to having
that code that you live by and the rules
and the code that i live by i'm never
going to betray that yeah so it's like
we've always said i may break up with
you one day because i'm not saying that
like oh there's nothing you could do
that would make me break up with you for
sure there is but i'm never gonna cheat
on you
i may come and say i'm breaking up with
you because i'm going to go have sex
with somebody else but i'm absolutely
not going to go have sex with somebody
behind your back never going to happen
so like having that trust and knowing
who the other person is like all that
stuff is is super meaningful and look
there's just more and more and more
stuff but those are some big ones
somebody taught me a long time ago a
very valuable lesson which is if you
do the right things on the top line the
bottom line will follow and what they
meant by that was if you get the right
strategy if you have the right people
and if you have the right culture
culture at your company you'll do the
right products you'll do the right
marketing you'll do the right things
logistically in manufacturing and
distribution and if you do all those
things right
the bottom line will follow i spoke at
an education summit for microsoft i also
spoke at an education summit for
apple
at the education from my at the
education summit for microsoft i would
say that 70 of the executives spent
about 70 of their presentations talking
about how to beat apple
at the apple education summit a hundred
percent of the executives spent a
hundred percent of their
presentations talking about how to help
teachers teach and how to help students
learn
one is playing this way and one is
playing that way
one is playing finite
and the other one is playing infinite
gets which one gets frustrated
so at the end of my talk at microsoft
they gave me a gift they gave me the new
zune when it was a thing
and let me tell you
this thing was spectacular
it was the most elegant piece of
technology i'd ever used the user
interface was incredible the design was
spectacular i absolutely loved it it was
easy to use and it was bright and
gorgeous and fanta it didn't work on
itunes which is a different problem so i
couldn't use it but but it was amazing
and elegant my god it was elegant
so i'm sitting in the back of a taxi
with a very senior apple executive sort
of employee number 12 kind of guy and
you know i like to stir pots so i turned
him i said you know
microsoft gave me their new zune
and it is so much better
than your ipod touch
and he turned to me and he said
i have no doubt
conversation over
because the infinite player understands
sometimes your head and sometimes you're
behind
sometimes your product is better and
sometimes it's worse
the goal isn't to be the best every day
the goal isn't to out to out do your
competition every day that's a finite
construction if i had said to microsoft
i've got the new ipod touch and it's so
much better than your zoom they would
have said can we see it what does it do
react react react react
finite players play to be to beat the
people around them
infinite players play
to be better than themselves
to wake up every single day and say how
can we make our company a better version
of itself today
than it was yesterday how can we create
a product
this week that's better than the product
we created last week we also have to
play the infinite game it's not about
being ranked number one it's not about
having more followers on twitter than
your friends
it's not about outdoing anyone it's
about how to outdo
yourself
it's not about selling more books or
getting more ted views than somebody
else it's about how to make sure that
the work that you're producing is better
than the work you produced
before
you are your competition
and that is what ensures you stay in the
game the longest and that is what
ensures you find joy
because the joy comes
not from comparison
but from advancement praise yourself
there is nothing
nothing
nothing
that will build your self-esteem like
praise but your praises if you have
a shoppers and so you look really great
in the outfit yeah it suits you you must
buy it they have an agenda if your boss
says you're amazing at your job but i
need to give you work to do over the
weekend they have an agenda
someone dating you might have an agenda
and your mind knows that when when you
say
i'm great at my job i'm smart i'm kind
i'm nice people like me
there is no agenda unfortunately when
you go i'm rubbish at my job i'm boring
i always mess up and i have no friends
your mind lets that into because your
mind doesn't really care if what you say
is right or wrong
good or bad healthy or unhealthy let me
prove that to you
i want you to put your hand in front of
your face like that i want you to close
your eyes i want you to imagine
you have a big fat juicy lemon and i
want you to
breathe in that wonderful lemon smell
and just squeeze it a bit and feel that
wonderful lemon texture because nothing
quite smells like a lemon so still
really believing you have half a lemon
in your hand
open your mouth
shove that lemon in there cram that half
a lemon into your mouth and start
chewing
and sucking and biting and swallowing
the flesh keep sucking all that lemon
flesh into your mouth bite it chew it
suck out the juice
and you will notice that what is
happening is
your body is responding to a thought as
if it's a fact
your body is responding to the image and
thought of eating a lemon as if you are
actually eating a lemon and it's making
a saliva because thoughts are things
and every thought you have
has a physical reaction in your body and
an emotional response to when you think
i don't have friends i can't talk to
people i can't take things back to a
store
i can't ask for special treatment
i don't know how to talk to people then
your mind accepts that as a fact just
like the lemon but when you say
oh i can talk to anyone i'm an
interesting person i'm warm and friendly
people like me and i can make eye
contact i'm good at my job i can ask
someone out on a date i can tell the
person i'm involved with what i need
your mind accepts that too and someone
recently said they keep a lemon on their
desk now and look at it every day i'm
sure they change it every month because
that lemon reminds them every day that
they are responsible for what they think
and feeling you know responsibility that
word means an ability to respond
so i want you to start to praise
yourself i want you to wake up in the
morning the first thing you go is i like
myself you might have a great mindset
positive thinking but if you have a
heart set full of anger if your
emotional life is sad if you're
disappointed from the past if you
haven't done that the sweat lodges and
the journaling and the body work and the
affirmations to really open up a heart
set then you can have
the mindset of elon musk you have the
mindset of a steve jobs you can have a
mindset of a kobe but you're going to
sabotage yourself from world class and
to me this is the great myth of positive
thinking you see a lot of people they
read all the books they're positive
thinkers they've got the vision boards
nothing changes why
because subconsciously
there's this wounding
and a lack of deservability and it's
unconscious and so they haven't done the
work or you may have not done the work
to make the
wounds of undeservability and scarcity
and the low self-worth that's why
positive thinking alone does not work
this is to me a revolutionary insight
and by the way a lot of the people who
teach positive thinking in the past
are men
so it's very male
mind
and a lot of the people who are pioneers
of heart heartset are women
heart
empathy
healing
and so
self-mastery to me
and this is a pioneering model that i
teach
at personal mastery academy it's not
just mindset that's only 25 of self
mastery and as you know self mastery is
the dna of outer mastery you're never
going to perform higher than what's
going on within
mindset is only 25
heart set
your emotional life
working from confidence and love
and service
and that sense of internal freedom is
only another 25 so those two are only 50
there's a third interior empire you want
to get to world class which is health
set
working on your energy your nutrition
your daily exercise hacking your
longevity eating the right supplements
getting a massage every two weeks you
know my two massage protocol
doing your 60 minute nature walk every
week so that your
health set is at world class but that's
only 75 of the equation towards self
mastery you have a great mindset great
heart set great health set but if you
haven't worked on your soul set
turning down your ego you know you know
what disease and what energy depletion
is caused by your ego beating you
relentlessly about you not being enough
and seeing your industry peers
succeeding and you feel
insecure and irritated and angry and
jealous well where do you do that work
within your soul set the fourth interior
empire
and as you do that you turn down the ego
and you open up your humanity and you
open up your spiritual life and you
become more soulful and then you release
work that is artistry versus just to win
in the next few months when you
literally give your life over to a
mighty mission that is larger than your
ego and you literally start to see your
work as a ministry for the benefit of
humanity and if you literally if you're
an artist or an entrepreneur or ceo
manager a coder a doctor or a fighter
firefighter but literally if you saw
your work as your poetry and your
artistry and you were on a mighty
mission that was larger than even your
your ego
and yourself
connecting increases your influence
in every situation
for the foundation of the teaching today
i want to make sure that we really have
a grasp of why connecting with people is
so vital
so if you go to the very first sentence
in your note the number one criteria for
advancement and promotion for
professionals
is an ability to communicate effectively
that i do believe
i think the ability to connect and
communicates the number one criteria for
success with your family with your
marriage with your children with your
friends in the workplace the marketplace
in the community
if you have the ability to connect with
people if you can communicate and
connect not just communicate
it takes you and literally gives you and
i a decided edge over others in the
advancement of what we're trying to
accomplish for example
in your notes presidential historian
robert dalek says that the success that
successful presidents exhibit five
skills and qualities that enable them to
achieve things that others don't
so he's talking about leaders and
presidents and people what makes some
achieve better than others here's the
five things they do well number one is
vision
number two pragmatism
number three
consensus building
the ability to put together a team and
get consensus
number four charisma
and number five trustworthiness
being a trustworthy kind of a person
now what is interesting about these five
uh
these five things that set the better
presidents apart from maybe the average
ones four of the five
deal with connecting
vision is a definitely a connecting
skill the ability to to cast a future
vision consensus building getting people
to work together you have to be able to
connect to do that charisma of course
that's why people follow the quote the
pied piper and trustworthy four of the
five
of the skills needed to be successful as
a leader had a lot to do with connecting
so let me define connecting because
that's what this book is all about
connecting is the ability
to identify with people
and relate to them in such a way that it
increases our influence with them
in other words we can identify with them
until they say
he or she understands exactly what i
know and what i'm going through and we
can relate with them until we because of
that ability we begin to increase our
influence with them and of course what
do i teach about leadership very simple
leadership is
influence if you're going to be
great at something you've got to make
the effort to be great at something
whether it's sports whether it's physics
math science business whatever it may be
you know it's not just a natural skill
you've got you've got to to learn and
particularly if you're in the technology
industry because it changes every day
you know
when i got started and and you know
after i got i i got it i was a bartender
when i first came to dallas got into the
pc industry got fired started my own
company but
there i learned early on that there was
always something new
and most people didn't put in the time
to learn it it's like now with
artificial intelligence lots of people
talk about artificial intelligence lots
of people talk about machine learning
and neural networks not a lot of people
are putting in the time to take classes
or do the tutorials or to learn how to
apply it to business and that's what it
takes and and you know that's just
something i've always enjoyed so that
i've been fortunate at that now wait a
minute are you doing that with ai right
absolutely what are you doing oh i mean
i've been on amazon doing the machine
learning tutorials right now i'm going
through um i've taken python online
classes really yeah absolutely um if you
go in my bathroom there's a machine
learning for dummies book um i just
started javascript neural networks um
there's a little tutorial where they've
got most of the library brain.js and all
the libraries and it's not if you have a
background in programming it's not hard
but i'm not trying to be great at that
but i want to understand it so i
understand all the you know so i the
nuanced elements of it and how it works
so that i have an advantage you know i
the number one thing i got from mit was
confidence and the ability to think for
myself
that's the number one thing uh my my
first serious formative memory of mit as
i walk into a material science class
there's 350 people in the lecture hall
the professor walks out and he is a
consultant for nasa
and he's the top of his profession and
he designed these tiles that went on the
space shuttle and he takes one of the
tiles and is burnt it's got streaks on
he holds up from the class he says you
know on the space shuttle's last
re-entry this tile burned off the space
shuttle nobody at nasa knows why and
we're not sure how to fix it what do you
think
okay and this is this is the first class
the first week freshman year we're all
18 year olds and it's a bunch of people
that are like the class valedictorian
from their various schools
and everybody looks at everybody and
there's a pregnant pause for 60 seconds
and you could see what's going on in
people's minds because first they're
like oh my god is there a reading i
missed
is and the second thought is
wait a minute the answer to this
question is not in the back of the book
and the third you know and then at some
point someone raised in here and says
you know well maybe we should reverse
the composite lattices or or change the
material to something
and everybody goes oh my god that must
be the most br the bravest student in
the world
and it dawns on all of us that this
professor who's the smartest in the
world at what he does working for the
leading space agency in the world
doesn't have an answer to a fundamental
problem has never been answered in the
history of the human race he's looking
at a bunch of people he expects you to
think for yourself and figure it out and
he thinks maybe you can
and that idea that
you can actually uh
solve a problem for the first time in
human history
and you're expected to do it and they're
going to t they're going to give you all
the basic tools
uh the math the engineering disciplines
the scientific method to do it i think
that's enormously confidence building at
the end of the day because the number
one thing you want to learn from your
education is how to think
how to think right how to solve problems
after that
everything else is useful it's good it
was good to have contacts it was good to
have
to have the social interaction of other
intense thinkers and yes i think that's
probably the second most valuable thing
i got at mit
but you know
i will say that
you know in the 10 years after i left
mit i worked 3 500 hours a year 70 hours
a week 50 weeks a year dealing with
problems never before encountered
and i didn't think it was particularly
difficult because it was so difficult
getting through those four years at mit
where i was working 80 to 90 hours a
week
intellectually
butting heads with the smartest
professors the smartest students and
trying to solve
fundamental problems
i kind of felt like it hardened me
intellectually to cope
in the real world and so i i appreciate
the fact that they gave me that kind of
tough love
you know they didn't give us a textbook
with 37 questions with the answers in
the back of the book
and let us memorize the answers take the
test
you know and give us a 95
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want seven more rich people habits for
you to try check the video right there
next to me i think you'll love it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there you absolutely must if you want to
be legendary in your marketplace you
absolutely have to do this schedule 60
minutes a day for your learning it could
be listening to audiobooks